in this video we'll talk about
x-linked a gamma Global anemia
this is a higher video for USMLE step
one
let's talk about the cause of x-linked a
gamma Global anemia so this is caused by
a mutation in the gene that encodes for
the kinase BTK
this BTK kinase is really important in
context of B cell development
BTK is a non-receptor tyrosine kinase
in this in this mutation BTK is not
produced or functional BTK is absent so
let's see what happens
but thing is why BTK is important
actually in the bone marrow while B cell
is developing
Pro B cell gets eventually converted to
pre-b cell and in this conversion
process there are several signaling
Cascades going on
one such Cascade is modulated by the
enzyme BTK
so once BTK is absent this particular
step of B cell development does not take
place
so if we put it simply that BTK
regulates several part of
important signaling pathway
BTK leads to activation of phospholipase
C beta thereby increasing the calcium
levels
in the B cells and that leads to several
Downstream changes but once BTK is
absent all these factors are not
happening
so in the overall maturation process BTK
takes a very important role
obviously we can now appreciate why BTK
gene mutation can lead to a B cell
maturation defect or B cell
developmental defect so proc Pro B cells
never become
plasma cells in this particular disease
it is why none of the antibodies are
generated so two important features of
this particular
ah disease is no B cell and no
antibodies that lead to a risk of
infection
when it comes to genetics this straight
is x-linked
and BTK gene mutation
is transmitted from a mother to
generally the male Childs because in the
male child there is no uh extra X
chromosome to counterbalance the faulty
X chromosome in a female there is always
a normal copy that can possibly counter
balance
the faulty copy
that's why generally females are the
carriers whereas the males are the
affected ones that's why this disease is
also known as x-linked a gamma global
global anemia
let's talk about the symptoms
so obviously if the B cells are absent
and the development doesn't happen then
you don't have antibodies the infants
with xla are having several throat ear
and lung infection
sometimes the infection is very serious
and it goes to central nervous system or
it damages internal organs
and these children tend to cope up well
with short viral infection but they are
susceptible to Chronic viral infections
such as hepatitis
they have a smaller size of tonsil
so let's talk about the treatment option
so gamma globulin infusion through the
vein is one of the way to treat this
disease so on a weekly basis or on like
once in a two week this kind of infusion
has to be injected which are generally
purified antibodies injected through the
veins
also supportive medicines like
antibiotics would reduce the risk of
bacterial infection
so I hope that was useful if you need
more notes and flashcards you can get
into my Facebook page or Instagram you
can support our Channel with super
thanks and thank you for listening see
you in next video